pis je me demandais si éventuellement tu
avais envie qu'on sorte tous les deux
c'est le dernier arrêté qui conclut la
fin du lycée la dernière chance de
décider qui on veut être et avec qui on
veut être
j'abandonne il faut s'habiller comme ans
pour une rupture
et si on se mettait d'accord pour rester
amis ne semble venir
allez courage à temps
possible ça devait être l'été du siècle
faut que tu tourne la page
tu es vraiment doué j'en reviens pas tu
gâches ce talent pour aller étudier le
commerçant au lieu d'une carrière stable
et tranquille dans l'artistique
ça aurait fait deux camps sur la plage
sapin bien sûr ouais
je vais pas sortir avec lui quand même
nom et les jeunes tout lui réussit et il
est canon c'est à vomir
en parlant d'avenir vous en êtes où tout
à fait dit on en a pas encore discuté
vous fait durer le mystère jusqu'au bout
je te comprend avec ya des moments où
j'ai peur de même pas être capable
d'aimer
[Musique]
bienvenue dans mon bureau
qu'il ne facilite pas la tâche pour te
juger
cet été parce beaucoup plus vite que je
croyais et j'avais envie de te voir
avant qu'on parte faire nos études salut
il faut que tu te laisses mais passé un
bon 4 juillet ok je suis dit il ya un
truc qu'il faut que je te dise
tu es rentré dans leur jeu et à rien je
ne savais pas quoi faire j'ai jamais été
confronté un truc pareil
[Musique]
dernière était
la dernière chance d'y aller à fond
c'est vrai qu est-ce qui a happé un
[Musique]